-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
all doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden today signed the
bipartisan infrastructure
bill into law.
And I think it's good that
he's finally taking action
against the dilapidated
and crumbling approval rating.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
did not attend today's
signing ceremony
for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill.
But in another middle finger to
the Right, Big Bird did.
Former President Trump released
a statement on Saturday
encouraging primary campaigns
against Republican House members
who voted for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill and said,
"Saving America starts by
saving the GOP from
RINOs, sellouts,
and known losers."
Take it from him,
all of those things.
In his new book,
former New Jersey governor
Chris Christie writes
that while he was hospitalized
with the coronavirus,
former president Trump
called him to ask him,
"Are you going to say you
got it from me?"
Aww! That's actually --
that's actually sweet.
Just like the card he sent when
Melania was pregnant.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now...
After Senator
Bernie Sanders tweeted,
"We must demand that
the extremely wealthy
pay their fair share,"
Tesla C.E.O. Elon Musk
replied yesterday and said,
"I keep forgetting
that you're still alive."
Wow. Well, that is one of
the side effects.
Vice President Kamala Harris
has reportedly told confidants
that she feels constrained
with what
she is able to do, politically,
in the Biden administration.
"Same," said Biden.
On a new episode of his podcast,
Joe Rogan said
that he's so flexible, he is
capable of performing oral sex
on himself, or, as he calls it,
"Doing my own research."
And, finally, Buckingham Palace
announced yesterday
that Britain's Queen Elizabeth
skipped a
Remembrance Day Ceremony
due to a sprained back muscle.
Apparently,
she heard that Rogan story
and wanted to give it a shot.
Picture it.
That was the monologue.
I mean,
we're not doing another one.